on that topic you kind of mention
information just to get a sense I
imagine something that there's still
mystery and disagreement on is how does
the brain carry information and signal
like what in your sense is the basic
mechanism of communication in the brain
well I I guess I'm old-fashioned in that
I consider the networks that we use in
deep learning research to be a
reasonable approximation to you know the
the mechanisms that carry information in
the brain so the the the usual way of
articulating that is to say what really
matters is a rate code it what matters
is how how how quickly is an individual
in their own spiking half you know
what's the frequency at which it's
spiking is it the timing of the spike
yeah is it is it firing fast or slow
let's you know let's put a number on
that and that number is enough to
capture what what neurons are doing
there's you know there's still
uncertainty about whether that's an an
adequate description of how information
is is transmitted within the brain
there you know there are there are
studies that suggest that the precise
timing of spikes matters there are
studies that suggest that there are
computations that go on within the
dendritic tree within a neuron that are
quite rich and structured and that
really don't equate to anything that
we're doing in our artificial neural
networks having said that I feel like we
can get I feel like I feel like we're
getting somewhere by sticking to this
high level of abstraction just the rate
and by the way we're talking about the
electrical signal that I remember
reading some vague paper somewhere
recently where the mechanical signal
like the vibrations or something of the
of the neurons also communicates if I
haven't seen that but this is there
somebody was arguing that the the
electrical signal this is in nature
paper something like that where the
electrical signal is actually a side
effect
of the mechanical signal but I don't
think they changes the story but it's
almost an interesting idea that there
could be a deeper it's like it's always
like in physics with quantum mechanics
there's always a deeper story that could
be underlying the whole thing but you
think is basically the rate of spiking
that gets us that's like the lowest
hanging fruit that can get us really far
this is a this is a classical view I
mean this is this is this is not the
only way in which this stance would be
controversial is it you know in the
sense that there are there are members
of the neuroscience community who are
interested in alternatives but this is
really a very mainstream view the way
that neurons communicate is that
neurotransmitters arrive or you know at
a at you know they they wash up on a
neuron the neuron has receptors for
those transmitters that the the the the
meeting of the transmitter with these
receptors changes the voltage of the
neuron and if enough voltage change
occurs then a spike occurs right one of
these like discrete events and it's that
spike that is conducted down the axon
and leads to neurotransmitter release
this is just this is just like
neuroscience 101 this is like the way
the brain is supposed to work now what
we do when we build artificial neural
networks of the kind that are now
popular in the AI community is that we
don't worry about those individual
spikes we just worry about the frequency
at which those spikes are being
generated and the you know we consider
people talk about that as the activity
of a neuron and you know so the the
activity of units in a deep learning
system is you know broadly analogous to
the spike rate of a neuron there there
are people who who believe that there
are other forms of communication in the
brain in fact I've been involved in some
research recently that suggests that the
the voltage the voltage fluctuations
that occur in populations of neurons
that aren't
you know that are sort of below the
level of a spike production may be
important for for communication but I'm
still pretty old school in the sense
that I think that the the things that
we're building in AI research constitute
reasonable models of how a brain would
work
let me ask just for fun a crazy question
because I can do you think it's possible
were completely wrong about the way this
basic mechanism of your neuronal
communication that the information is
thought is some very different kind of
way in the brain oh heck yes I mean I
would look I wouldn't be a scientist if
I didn't think there was any chance we
were wrong
but but I mean if you look if you look
at the history of deep learning research
as it's been applied to neuroscience of
course the vast majority of deep
learning research these days isn't about
neuroscience but you know if you go back
to the 1980s there's a you know sort of
an unbroken chain of research in in
which a particular strategy is taken
which is hey let's train a deep a deep
learning system let's train a
multi-layer neural network on this task
that we trained our you know rat on or
our monkey on or this human being on and
then let's look at what the unit's deep
in the system are doing and let's ask
whether what they're doing resembles
what we know about what neurons deep in
the brain are doing and over and over
and over and over that strategy works in
the sense that the learning algorithms
that we have access to which typically
send our own back propagation they give
rise to you know patterns of activity
patterns of response patterns of like
neuronal behavior and these in these
artificial models that look haunting
lisa hauntingly similar to what you see
in the brain and you know is that a
commune
yes incidences at a certain point it
starts looking like such coincidence is
unlikely to not be deeply meaningful
yeah
yeah the circumstantial evidence is
overwhelming but it could be always open
to total flippin a table yeah of course
you